in the space of just a few hours today
Lebanon saw perhaps the beginning of the
change that most here seem to crave but
also the fragility of a country that
could still spiral after 13 days of
continuous countrywide secular protests
the Prime Minister Saad Hariri had made
a decision and late in the afternoon he
announced it had gone for 13 days the
Lebanese people have waited for a
decision for a political solution that
would stop the deterioration i've tried
during this period to find a way out to
listen to the people's voice and to
protect the country from economic
security and social dangers today i will
not hide it from them
i've reached a dead end behind him on
the wall the portrait is of his father
Rafiq Hariri former prime minister
assassinated in 2005 the victim of
sectarian conflict that's never far away
and outside in the hours just before the
resignation signs of those tensions were
clear martyrs square in Beirut one focus
for the days of peaceful protests turned
violent
the tents and stalls that have been the
focus of a carnival-like atmosphere were
ripped up and pulled down this wasn't
the police or the army moving in it was
supporters of two Shia organizations
Hezbollah and the Amal movement their
position in government is weakened by
the fall of the political system the
police did move in after a bit but in
Lebanon it's the various religious
movements who hold the power not the
security forces whether Hezbollah men
didn't go there was space for
satisfaction that one of the protester
demands had been met the PM had gone the
Lebanese people are one they chanted it
has been a theme of what they've called
their revolution for 13 days no
political or religious divides they've
even surprised themselves we are going
to not come out of the street until the
government steps down and a new
government is going to come up that
there are professionals and they are
don't
long to any sectarianism tonight back in
the central square the tents are being
put up again the PM is gone but the fear
is that the political establishment will
try and rejigged their own from within
and on the streets up and down this
country the change they're demanding
goes well beyond the Prime Minister Mark
Stone Sky News